okay I wasn't going to talk about
Michelle wolf and the White House
Correspondents Dinner since we normally
don't really say much about it but the
scandal around it has made me want to
have a conversation about it and what
was notable this this year about the
White House Correspondents Dinner was
that Trump didn't attend normally the
president goes they get roasted to some
degree and they generally take it pretty
well Michelle wolf headlined the event
in Trump's absence she made jokes some
were aggressive some were less
aggressive some were very funny some
were not as funny but she's getting
absolutely crushed by conservative media
and even some on the not right like not
left wingers per se but even just sort
of some general media criticism is
saying that maybe Michelle wolf went too
far and the normal MO with these things
is the people being made fun of it's
usually the president people in the
current administration sometimes media
as well they sort of all take it in
stride right because it doesn't look
good when you don't and then the
partisan analysts from the
administration's party will slam the
comedian is going too far or being too
aggressive or being insensitive or
distasteful when it was Obama you'd hear
a little bit of that from the left but
mostly it was understood that this is
comedy right it's comedy and it's comedy
period the right has absolutely lost its
mind over Michelle Wolf's joke saying
everything from it was bullying that was
Mike Huckabee who said that - it was
cruel unfair disgusting inaccurate and
this is so funny on so many levels first
and foremost being the same free speech
warriors who were supposedly against the
trigger warnings and the safe spaces are
effectively totally triggered by
Michelle wolf and arguing that she just
went too far and they wanted in practice
the White House Correspondents Dinner to
be a safer space for them than it was I
mean just a glaring hypocrisy but I
thought we should actually look at what
Michelle Wolf said because what really
seems to be getting to them is that
everything Michelle Michelle Wolf said
other than like the clearly sarcastic or
joking comments was true right she
opened with a joke about a porn star
having sex with Trump that happened or
at least there's every indication that
it happened she said Congress
accomplishes
little that's true most people in the
United States degree she said that at
age 32 she's 20 years older than the age
that would make ROI more find her
attractive more hasn't denied pursuing
girls not that much older than 12 right
it's an edgy joke but it's a fine joke
to be making she referred to Michael
Cohen writing a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar check to someone he did
that what's the big deal she joked about
the liberal media being turned on by the
Trump Russia collusion story that's a
critique of liberal media why would
conservatives be mad about that
she said Hillary wasn't in contact with
Michigan that's a critique of Hillary
Clinton's campaign she joked about Trump
phoning into Fox & Friends
he does phone into Fox & Friends all the
time why is that a big deal she joked
about maybe Trump isn't as rich as he
says he is well we know that that's
something that bothers Trump it's not
original material others have suggested
that she said Trump is a racist I mean
yeah that's a matter of debate but it's
not really unique or controversial at
this point to say that Trump has racist
tendencies she suggested that a Trump
impeachment might be bad because it
would lead to Mike Pence who's worse
I've been saying that and many others
have been saying that for more than a
year I don't see how that's offensive
she joked about people being against
abortion until their secret mistress
needs an abortion that's a real story
about many Republicans and even some
anti-choice Democrats when it comes to
abortions only for their mistresses and
not for anybody else she joked about
Republicans having not see candidates
that just happened in Illinois that
actually is a real thing
she said Kellyanne Conway lies that's
undeniably true
she said Ivanka has done nothing as a
women's rights advocate I would agree
with that and then she got into Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and this made a lot of
people mad she joked that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is like aunt Lydia in a
Handmaid's Tale she accused Sarah
Huckabee Sanders of constant lying she
joked about Sarah Huckabee Sanders being
a disappointment to women is this really
that bad like you would only really be
triggered by that if you recognize that
it's all completely true and then she
made a joke about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
Smokey Eye Makeup and people said well
is she starting to make fun of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
parents give me a break they should all
be thrilled that that's the full extent
to which Sarah Huckabee Sanders
appearance was ridiculed right and I've
been very clear I think Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is terrible for the lies that
she tells but one could if they wanted
to is Trump did too many of his opposing
Republican candidates ridicule the way
they look
joked about Fox News having a problem
with predators of women I mean that that
is true that's true made some jokes
about Rachel Maddow that's not even
about the ride she said Trump is so
broke that he grabs [ __ ] looking for
loose change I mean that that relates to
news stories if this is offensive speech
to Republicans they are even more
thin-skinned than we thought and we
thought they were pretty damn
thin-skinned and I feel like if there is
legitimate criticism to make here it's
that these aren't really jokes for the
most part there were just like
observations about reality yes and I
think that's why comedians nowadays are
having such a tough time in the era of
Trump because reality is already pretty
hilarious so there's nowhere to take it
I mean you can't like flip it you can't
make it satirical you can't exaggerate
it and then they could argue that it
wasn't funny that would be a criticism
but most people don't get offensive by
things that aren't funny they just don't
laugh and then move on with their lives
so it appears that what the right really
hated about Michelle wolf speech was
that it contained mostly the truth
there's one other angle here which is
that because Michelle wolf did go after
corporate media in a lot of ways
corporate media may have decided to
enable Michelle Wolf's critics to come
on and slam her because she slammed them
during her jokes that's another possible
angle which is interesting yeah it could
be a silver lining that this could take
down the White House Correspondents
Dinner they're actually talking about
getting rid of the comedy not only over
this incident but also Stephen Colbert's
roasting of George W Bush yeah that
would be a great thing I think the
Correspondents Dinner is a little bit
too cozy between the media and those in
charge so well I'd like to see them get
rid of it listen you got rid of the
president this year they can get rid of
the jokes next year what will be left I
guess just like a a dried fish dish that
gets served to everybody in the room I
don't know what else they'll have the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to
port the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad